así vivió estiren el lunes 3 de mayo en
el barrio de siloé de cali a las 9 de la
noche el en mar empieza una arremetida
pero más que arremetida puede tiro otra
desgaste y empezaron a disparar aquí no
hubo enfrentamientos la gente empezó a
correr hacia el interior del barrio y
adentro estaba esperando más policía que
empezó a disparar el barrio popular
lleno el martes las calles para
homenajear a las víctimas de las balas
en un grito desesperado
a nosotros nos toca limpiar en la sangre
que han dejado los asesinos de nuestro
barrio nos toca limpiar a nosotros la
sangre nosotros nadie sabe lo que es la
verdadera lucha hasta que están frente a
frente contra asesinos los vecinos piden
paz
sin embargo denuncian el abandono del
estado y la violencia policial una
violencia que preocupa a la directora de
un colegio del barrio
yo como como puedo
esparcir este mensaje de esperanza entre
los niños y ellos están viendo esta
realidad
durante el acto se encendieron velas y
se desplegó una bandera herida
colombiana les acompañan francia-
márquez premio goldman y candidata a la
presidencia de colombia en el año 2022
me duele mucho
y saber qué
y mama que todos los días les están
matando a sus hijos en estos barrios
la comunidad está formada en su mayoría
por desplazados del conflicto armado
como colectivos afrodescendientes e
indígenas el tejido social es parte de
su historia imagínense que la gente no
le da miedo contagiarse del virus de
amami o morirse de hambre le da más
miedo que los impuestos se lo coman y
que se desaparezca la clase media y por
ende la clase popular y es desde ese
sentido de comunión que aseguran que han
perdido el miedo a la violencia del
estado